- Welcome back y'all.
We're here with Cher.
Give it up.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Her new Cher Decades Eau de Parfum
is available online and in
select retailers right now.
Well, many people are obsessed with Cher
and understandably so, I am.
But what is Cher obsessed with? Who knows.
It's time to find out with
another round of Obsessions.
(gentle whimsical music)
- [Announcer] Obsessions.
(audience cheering)
- So how this game
works is we hit a button
on our super computer and it
will randomly select a topic
either Cher or I obsess over.
Then we have to really sell our obsession
and why it's so great
and why we're into it.
So since I'm not there, Marcel,
would you bring Cher our super computer.
We're super rich. (laughs)
Ooh, what?
I've never seen that button.
That's a, they gave you a
new whole bedazzled button.
I love that. Okay, wait.
I'm very impressed, art department.
Okay so, Cher.
(audience clapping)
So if you wouldn't mind
hitting that button on top
because, well, I can't.
- Okay.
(roulette dinging)
- [Kelly] It's a good button push.
(roulette sharply dings)
Oh, Bunnyville. Okay.
Well it sounds like a houseman
went back in a Western film
but it's not. (laughs)
Bunnyville, I have, me and my
kids, we have three bunnies
and I'm obsessed right
now, 'cause I feel bad.
Putting animals in cages bothers me a bit.
So, I mean, I know you have
to sometimes, whatever,
but like, so I'm building
in my backyard, like,
I call it Bunnyville.
It's ridiculous.
It's like they have their
own little theme park
in my backyard and there's
just three bunnies,
so I'm obsessed with them. (laughs)
(audience applauding)
Do you like, do you have any animals?
- Well, I rescued an elephant in Islamabad
and took him to Cambodia.
(audience applauding)
- Way to trump me with that. Wait, what?
(laughs) Like, what?
That's incredible. That's so cool.
- I know. It's happened on Twitter.
I got all these kids
saying, "Save Kaavan,"
hashtag whatever.
And so I start
(audience chuckling)
and I thought, I'm like, I'm
gonna go save a elephant,
I'm just a singer, you know?
So we started fighting
and it took us four years,
and then I think that they knew something.
They said, "Okay, you can have him
but only if Cher picks him up."
So obviously they don't know me. So, yeah.
- (laughs) They didn't
think you'd show up.
- Uh-uh. I showed up,
I showed up big time.
And then we brought him,
and he's so beautiful,
then we brought him to Cambodia.
- It's a really cool thing that,
especially people with you,
it's just a giant spotlight,
highlight that and actually make change.
But now it's your turn, Cher.
So you press the button for you.
- [Announcer] Obsessions.
(roulette dinging)
(roulette sharply dings)
(audience wooing)
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Okay.
- Elvis?
- Yeah, when I was 10 years old
my mom took me to the
Pan Pacific to see Elvis.
I just, I really loved him.
And then when I got older,
not this old but older, he
invited me to Las Vegas.
(audience wooing)
- He what?
- One of his people
called, close your mouth.
(audience laughing)
One of his people,
one of his people called and said,
"Would you like to come
up for the weekend?"
And I was so terrified
that I couldn't do it.
(audience oohing)
Oh, shut up. (laughs)
- What?
When Elvis says, "Let's hang out,"
just, you go for the story.
- Right, but it was, he was on
the other side of, you know,
he was on the downside of himself, so.
(audience laughing)
- Oh.
- And I don't mean like,
handsome, whatever, like that,
but he was on the downside of
the drugs and stuff like that.
- That was maybe a smart decision.
Okay. Okay.
- Yeah.
- That was a really good obsession.
- Right, you don't wanna get
involved with another musician
who does drugs, I did that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's not fun.
So everybody, I can't
believe we ended with Elvis.
That was incredible, Cher.
Those are our obsessions.
(gentle whimsical music)
- [Announcer] Obsessions.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Well, everyone be sure to go
and get Cher's new fragrance collection.
I promise you they smell really good.
It's called Cher Decades Eau de Parfum.
And it's available online
and also in select retailers right now.